PROFESSOR: In order to learn
more about this subject,
we must do the wave packets.
So this is the place
where you really
connect this need solution
of Schrodinger's equation,
the energy eigenstates,
to a physical problem.
So we'll do our wave packets.
So we've been dealing
with packets for a while,
so I think it's not going to
be that difficult. We've also
been talking about
stationary phase
and you've practiced that,
so you have the math ready.
We should not have
a great difficulty.
So let's new wave packets with--
I'm going to use A
equals 1 in the solution.
Now, I've erased every
solution, and we'll
work with E greater than
v naught to begin with.
The reason I want to work
with E greater than v naught
is because there is
a transmitted wave.
So that's kind of nice.
So what am I going to do?
I'm going to write it
this following way.
So here is a solution
with A equals to 1.
e to the i kx plus k
minus k bar over k plus k
bar e to the minus i kx.
And this was for x less than 0.
And indeed, when there
was an A, there was a B,
if A is equal to 1, remember we
solve for the ratio of B to A
and it was this number
so I put it there.
I'm just writing it
a little differently,
but this is a solution.
And for x greater
than 0, the solution
is C, which was 2k over k
plus k bar e to the i k bar x.
Now we have to
superimpose things.
But I will do it very slowly.
First, is this a solution of
the full Schrodinger equation?
No.
Is this a solution a
time-independent Schrodinger
equation?
What do I need to
make it the solution
of the full
Schrodinger equation?
I need e to the
minus i Et over h.
And I need it here as well.
And this is a psi
now of x and t.
There's two options for x,
less than 0 and x less than 0,
and those are solutions.
So far so good.
Now I'm going to
multiply each solution.
So this is a solution of the
full Schrodinger equation,
not just the time-independent
one, all of it.
It has two expressions
because there's
a little discontinuity in
the middle, but as a whole,
it is a solution.
That is the solution.
Some mathematicians would
put a theta function here,
theta of minus x and add
this with a theta of x so
that this one exists for
less than x, x less than 0,
and this would exist
for less greater than 0.
I would not do that.
I will write cases, but
the philosophy is the same.
So let's multiply
by a number, f of k.
Still a solution.
k is fixed, so this
is just the number.
Now superposition.
That will still
be a solution if I
do the same superposition in
the two formulas, integral dk
and integral dk.
That's still a solution
of a Schrodinger equation.
Now I want to ask
you what limits
I should use for that integral.
And if anybody has
an opinion on that,
it might naively be minus
infinity to infinity,
and that might be good,
but maybe it's not so good.
It's not so good.
Why is not so good, minus
infinity to infinity?
Would I have to do from
minus infinity on my force.
Does anybody force me?
No.
You're superimposing solutions.
For different values of
k, you're superimposing.
You had a solution,
and another solution
for another, another solution.
What goes wrong if I go from
minus infinity to infinity?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the wave
packet's going to be in one
direction, so it [? shouldn't
?] be [? applied. ?]
PROFESSOR: That's right.
You see here, this
wave packet is
going to be going in the
positive x direction,
positive direction, as
long as k is positive.
It's just that the direction is
determined by the relative sign
within those quantities.
E is positive in this
case. k is positive.
This moves to the right.
If I start putting things
where k is negative,
I'm going to start producing
things and move to the left
and to the right in
a terrible confusion.
So yes, it should go 0 to
infinity, 0 to infinity.
And f of k, what is it?
Well, in our usual
picture, k f of k
is some function that is
peaked around some k naught.
And this whole thing
is psi of x and t,
the full solution
of a wave packet.
So now you see how the
A, B, and C coefficients
enter into the construction
of a wave packet.
I look back at the
textbook in which I
learned quantum mechanics,
and it's a book by Schiff.
It's a very good book.
It's an old book.
I think was probably
written in the '60s.
And it goes through some
discussion of wave packets
and then presents a jewel,
says with a supercomputer,
we've been able to evaluate
numerically these things,
something you can do now with
three seconds in your laptop,
and it was the only
way to do this.
So you produce an f of k.
You fix their energy and
send in a wave packet
and see what happens.
You can do numerical
experiments with wave packets
and see how the packet gets
distorted at the obstacle
and how it eventually
bounces back or reflects,
so it's very nice.
So there is our solution.
Now we're going to say
a few things about it.
I want to split it a little bit.
So lets go here.
So how do we split it?
I say the solution
is this whole thing,
so let's call the
incident wave that
is going to be defined
for x less than 0
and t, this is x less than 0.
And the incident
wave packet is dk 0
to infinity f of k e to i kx e
to the minus i et over h bar.
And this is just defined
for x less than 0,
and that's so important
that write it here.
For x less than 0, you have
an incident wave packet.
And then you also have
a reflected wave packet,
x less than 0 t is
the second part dk
f of k k minus k bar over k
plus k bar e to the minus i kx
e to the minus i et over h bar.
It's also for x
less than 0, and we
have a psi transmitted for
x greater than 0 and t,
and that would be 0 to infinity
dk f of k 2k over k plus k bar
e to the i k bar x e to
the minus i et over h bar.
Lots of writing, but
that's important.
And notice given
our definitions,
the total psi of x and t is
equal to psi incident plus psi
reflected for x less than 0,
and the total wave function of x
and t is equal to
psi transmitted
for x greater than 0.
Lots of equations.
I'll give you a second to copy
them if you are copying them.
So now comes if we really
want to understand this,
we have to push it
a little further.
And perhaps in exercises we
will do some numerics to play
with this thing as well.
So I want to do stationary
phase approximation here.
Otherwise, we don't
see what these packets,
how they're moving.
So you have some practice
already with this.
You're supposed to have a
phase whose derivative is 0,
and it's very, very
slowly at that place where
there could be a contribution.
Now every integral
has the f of k.
So that still dominates
everything, of course.
You see, if f of
k is very narrow,
you pretty much could
evaluate these functions
at the value of k naught
and get a rather accurate
interpretation of the answer.
The main difficulty would
be to do the leftover
part of the integral.
But again, here we
can identify phases.
We're going to take f of k to
be localized and to be real.
So there is no phase
associated with it,
and there is no
phases associated
with these quantities either,
so the phases are up there.
So let's take, for
example, psi incident.
What is this stationary
phase condition?
Would be that the
derivative with respect
to k that we are
integrating of the phase,
kx minus Et over h bar must
be evaluated at k naught
and must be equal to 0.
So that's our stationary
phase approximation
for the top interval.
Now remember that E is equal
to h squared k squared over 2m.
So what does this give you?
That the peak of the
pulse of the wave packet
is localized at the place where
the following condition holds.
x minus de dk, with an h bar
will give an h k t over m
evaluated at k naught equals 0.
So this will be x equals
h bar k naught over m t.
That's where the incident
wave is propagating.
Now, look at that incident wave.
What does it do
for negative time?
As time is infinite and
negative, x is negative,
and it's far away.
Yes, the packet is very much
to the left of the barrier
at time equals minus infinity.
And that's consistent
because psi incident is only
defined for x less than 0.
It's only defined there.
So as long as t is negative,
yes, the center of the packet
is moving in.
I'll maybe draw it here.
The center of the packet is
moving in from minus infinity
into the wall, and
that is the picture.
The packet is here, and
it's moving like that,
and that's t negative.
The psi incident is coming
from the left into the barrier,
and that's OK.
But then what happens with
psi incident as t is positive?
As t is positive, psi
incident, well, it's
just another integral.
You might do it and
see what you get,
but we can see what
we will get, roughly.
When t is positive, the answer
would be you get something
if you have positive x.
But psi incident is
only for negative x.
So for negative x, you cannot
satisfy the stationarity
condition, and therefore, for
negative x and positive time,
t positive, psi
incident is nothing.
It's a little wiggle.
There's probably
something, a little bit--
look at it with Mathematica--
there will be something.
But for positive t, since
you only look at negative x,
you don't satisfy
stationarity, so you're not
going to get much.
So that's interesting.
Somehow automatically
psi incident just
exists for negative time.
For time near 0 is very
interesting because somehow
stationary [INAUDIBLE],
when you assess,
you still get
something, but you're
going to see what the packet
does as it hits the thing.
Let's do the second
one of psi reflected.
d dk this time would be
kx with a different sign,
minus kx minus E t over h
bar at k naught equals 0.
For the reflected wave, the
phase is really the same.
Yeah, this factor is a
little more complicated,
but it doesn't have
any phase in it.
It's real, so [INAUDIBLE].
So I just change a
sign, so this time I'm
going to get the change of sign.
x is equal to minus h
bar k naught over m t.
And this says that for t
positive, you get things.
And in fact, as t is positive
your are at x negative.
And remember psi reflected is
only defined for x negative,
so you can satisfy
stationary, and you're
going to get something.
So for t positive,
you're going to get
as t increases, a thing that
goes more and more to the left
as you would expect.
So you will get psi
reflected going to the left.
I will leave for you to
do the psi transmitted.
It's a little different
because you have now k bar,
and you have to take
the derivative of k bar
with respect to k.
It's going to be a little
more interesting example.
But the answer is that this
one moves as x equals h bar k
bar over m t.
k bar is really the
momentum on the right,
and since psi transmitted
exists only for positive x,
this relation can be
satisfied for positive t.
For positive t, there
will be a psi transmitted.
The psi transmitted certainly
exists for negative t,
but for negative t, stationarity
would want x to be negative,
but that's not defined.
So for negative t on the right,
yes, psi transmitted maybe
it's a little bit of
something especially for times
that are not too negative.
But the picture is that
stationary phase tells you
that these packets,
psi incident,
pretty much exist just
for negative t and psi
reflected and psi transmitted
exist for positive t.
And these are
consequences of the fact
that psi incident and psi
reflected exist for negative x.
The other exists for
positive x, and that coupled
with stationarity produces
the physical picture that you
expect intuitively, that
the incident wave is just
something, part of
the solution that
exists just at the beginning.
And somehow it whistles away.
Some of it becomes transmitted,
some of it becomes reflected.